this is our real thoughts on Exorcist -
one of the most business issues one of
the most bizarre sequels that somehow is
boring um I don't know how you do that
it's a ok I'll give the director this
yet
some balls do some of these Sammy he
fucking dangled Linda Blair on the edge
of a building there is no Ned or
anything shielding carry me it's that
guy has done some really like kind of
daring bizarre risque stuff I mean city
including directing Exorcist - yes um
which William Friedkin by the way
apparently still has not seen that's
probably for the best
mm-hmm you know when was so what we
anytime our mom would leave like go out
of town for something our dad would
always sneak in at these scary movies
what we were younger you know I hate
here's alien here's aliens you know and
then stuff like that here's terminator
not he's gonna be watching now so oh she
knew she knew uh but and he would show
us Exorcist and I'm wasn't quite as
drawn in its like a real like wow that's
a scariest movie everybody I did know
I'm like this is scary like this is good
I always thought the first half of the
Exorcist when I was younger was scarier
than the second half actually all that
buildup is great and then in the end
like see now I'm the opposite I actually
thought the second half I was younger
was scary and now watching it again the
first half of scarier I guess like I was
a little older and I just could kind of
see through some of the effects and I
was kind of always aware at least to a
certain degree they were effects whereas
the first part was more atmosphere and
you know no I mean my pain the scariest
scene in that movie is just when he goes
in to the room and again it is that
build-up like Demi goes into the room
you cut to something else to come but
you just see the door open and nothing
is totally quiet and then you see him
just looking you token away he's looking
at and then you just see like if you're
to see it on so it wouldn't be like the
scariest thing but just the build-up to
dance the mother on the bed just glowing
with these dark eyes I'm just like
Ellsberg it scared him and they asked
and that was not like a boo or anything
like that was just like Oh scary you
know like that the funny thing is the
foggy night the tubular bells when
father marriage
walking up the stairs and something
terrifying just about that door yeah you
nailed it like you just know and it's
always cold in there and there's just
something evil in it like one you
probably when they get it it's still
good I think it's a good movie but it's
just kind of like it's almost like jaws
like when you finally see the shark they
can never quite live up to the
expectation of seeing those like like
swimmers like getting pulled down
earlier seeing the remains in the body
parts it's like when you know
what's-his-face gets eaten by the shark
at the end and it's like the roboshark
it just can't compare somehow like your
imagination like made it weak where you
drop a great point when they did the
re-release which I'm not against you
know they put in new scenes and stuff
like that a few new effects I did mine
cuz I thought i sorry added a new energy
to it a new spirit a you can still watch
the original so I think it's fine play
button no no but you brought up this
really great point this one scene that
got everyone screaming why is when she's
going backwards down the stairs and
everyone jump down laughs I light up
whoa no no no I mean to me it's like
when I first saw it again to the power
of the atmosphere and everything uh it
had that effect too and it put me this
uncomfortable state cuz I didn't know
what the hell they were going to do and
they did do a few extra things but yeah
a watching and now it's kind of funny
way you take it we take the atmosphere
out and be uh you said you know I didn't
like that because everything seemed to
be in that room you don't wanna go in
that room and that door that doors kept
closed was all converging to air out it
and you took her out of there and I
thought that was a great point she only
has a few scenes outside of the room in
kind of quasi possessed mode when she
tells ya that you're gonna like
everything real all the stuff happens in
that room I thought was a great way so
she comes out of the room it do is
really extreme crazy thing yeah and I
also thought from a pacing standpoint
that like the idea is even though I it
didn't always work because it's such a
great build-up that you almost you can't
quite get the deliver you would want
just like jaws to me would be like
seeing the entire shark like full shark
everything just a big scene are in the
air yeah at the end at the halfway point
so that when you see it later you're
going home when we already saw that like
it was kind of a pacing giveaway
like so I didn't like that scene there
are other little things I added I
thought were cute but yeah and we have
the original so so it's fine so then
this so bottom line that we got some
that's a great move really yeah so uh so
then the sequel is coming out and I was
kind of excited for cuz I was like man
that first access is that kind of like I
was a logistical film and I just do not
see legit scary films the sequel wasn't
coming out a sequel in no no no like
Dead is showing us exit oh you rented it
guy and she kinda didn't I don't think
he remembered I don't know if he saw it
or remember there whatever he's
remembered it as he thought it was
hilarious hmm
so he kind of showed it to us and we
were but he didn't tell us that we were
kind of like excited to see what was
gonna be and I membered the atmosphere
at Fir when I was younger I thought the
atmosphere was kind of there like it was
building up this weird surreal
comfortable atmosphere which I liked
but never delivered on the scares and
then when I got and and the climax even
back that by the climax being really
stupid uh and then when I got older
watch it again I'm like oh man that's
Pazuzu yeah ya know and then watching it
again I'm like oh man does this not work
like this really does not work it was a
weird well there's two mood that it's
two movies in one which I'm told I have
not seen any post Exorcist er II was not
interested still am NOT but I'm told
that one of the ones I went into father
meirin's back history it's kind of like
Exorcist too like they they go into the
possessions in Africa and that's part of
the problem is there's two separate
competing movies one is this detective
story like trying to figure out father
Maron's past and going back to then
puzzles and the other is like this kind
of just sequel to The Exorcist with
Linda Blair's in it and yeah ah the
demons coming back and it they're in the
room again there's the devil makeup
whatever I ask
it just didn't gel it's really I think
part of the problem is you know and it
sounds weird sometimes when people say
this but it is a case of trying way too
hard
mmm like there was so much so much shit
going on in this movie that I'm like had
you condensed one of these plots down
and separated them and just picked one
story you may have been able to get away
with some of this but like there's so
much good and then the pseudoscience of
like the flashing lights that ya know
that you know and that could have been
really the Blair within stairs that
there was something I almost liked about
like if the demon or somebody was
stopping the heart you could kind of see
the hand and then somebody else was
going to try and bring it back I kind of
like that Sloan is like you really
certainly could feel almost somebody was
actually going to die there and they
save the person's life of this look slow
method but then it goes a little too
literal when you see all of the demon
there all of the demon holding the heart
how creepy would be just see like a
handers are just I couldn't outline of a
hand there that's part of the problem it
the movie day no way much I don't think
Borman knew exactly what he wanted to
say with the like I think he had all
these ideas and he couldn't quite focus
cuz like that night a lot of his movies
yeah well there's the scientific aspect
of it and I'm like well this is kind of
interesting with the hypnosis and like I
actually kind of liked it I kind of like
thank you hims but did you have there's
way too much of it but then you had
listen your giveaway of like but then
you see the demon reaching out and I'm
like okay so this is a horror film again
but with this weird scientific aspect
and then by the end of it it goes
full-on crazy ass horror movie I mean
how much more 3d web BAM you were doing
that hypnotism thing and you just heard
the sounds or you saw little image I
need the scary thing that everyone
fucking remembers from the first film is
that one scary face at times screen not
even for a second during the dream
sequence and everyone takes that face
everybody repose everybody makes
t-shirts everybody Minds eyes because it
was just a snippet and how great would
have been if they incorporated that same
kind of usage in those hypnotism scenes
yeah I don't I don't know the weird
thing is I will say this it is a
fascinating trainwreck it's a Boorman
film so even as bad films is like well
they're interesting they're at least
interesting and how they feel yeah but
but it's so weird cuz it's not like it's
both so weird and interesting and boring
as hell because it's the hiding like
this
Photography half the time is
legitimately insanely good it's like a
Kubrick film and then I'm just like and
I'm so uninterested in what's going on
like a bad guy who who they get to play
the priest again and all Richard Burton
Oh Stanley me stumbling around boring
drunk like oh yeah no that's right he
was right yeah I think I think he was
like drunk until like literally just
like stumbling or no boring cannot hold
this film I mean it's like I'm saying
like at least I mean when James Earl
Jones shows up it's like in the fucking
fairy tale of everything I mean it's
like yes I mean he he looks ridiculous
but it's like it's James Earl Jones he
he he's gonna grab me he's gonna getcha
cuz I'm he's just such a fuckin act for
Linda Blair trying yeah yeah it's like
an you knew she's got nothing to work
with in like that I think I don't was
I'm trying to think of her career that
was pre or post exploitation film Blair
pebble Bank it was after yeah prep
probably maybe somewhere in the middle I
don't know cuz she being started into
that pretty Amit yeah it's like you can
just tell this movie gave her nothing
the Klingon indexing you know it's gonna
be a prison escape movie some women's
prison film it's like you can see that
she's got the dead stare in her eye like
how I'm gonna do women's prison films
after this are and I like it just Oh
but yeah it's like she's trying but this
script gives her nothing to do um it you
know what it is
it was weird by forgot to be interesting
yeah the the ending but the funny thing
is like there are so many things in this
room I love just from a what the fuck
were you thinking about the the flying
Pazuzu shot I love that it's so
ridiculous the the the African boy
flinger that the fucking ending with her
like dueling like just oh it's like the
boy
oh why would I know cuz I fell when we
ever saw it when were younger I fell
asleep and then I asked you how it ended
and you're just like oh shit how do I
even explain it he fell asleep he's like
how the movie and I'm like oh there was
the woman's set on fire then Richard
Burton walks up then it's it's Linda
Blair's hair as well but then there's a
possessed Pazuzu version she's like no
and then the priest and and and the evil
version like totally like make out like
that and like Linda plays like he's like
he loves pazoozas Regan and then there's
locusts and the home rips apart the
floor falls out and the bed falls and
stuff and is that you say all this crazy
extreme stuff away doesn't sound scary
at all no no it wasn't I was like no but
it was like holy shit what the hell um
it made the if the fighting has it made
the one the ending from Exorcist 3 which
was equally insanely what the fuck like
just look like a walk in the park my man
when this movie came out like all the
critics is that consistent this is
during the 70s I need a job boring it
was a very experimental and stuff and I
think I mean I like it like fucking
Excalibur's one of my favorites I love
it yeah yeah but so so there's always so
people were kind of like open to the
weirdness but they just didn't know what
to think of it then when they really
lets it they're like yeah this wasn't
very good and it is such like late 70s
kind of weirdness and yeah I like all
over it um which again can be fun if you
can do it interestingly and it's just
it's it's like I say it's weird but it's
not interesting and then we go into
Exorcist 3 which is such a shame cuz
that's a lick I wish it was before we
move on okay you know outside of the Sun
a philosophically they were interesting
things going on in nexuses - which is
one of the reasons it pisses me off
um it's kind of like the half a Star
Wars films like Revenge of the Sith
we're just like oh there's like
interesting things I just wish yeah
perfect couldn't work it was just a
light I like the idea of like you know
the devil attacks these innocent kids
these healers and the connection between
her in the African boy would have been
fine if you found a different way to
shout shoot it with
I'm going Lulu yeah like so there's like
I thought those things were kind of
interesting like going to Africa I
thought was it's like every city the
funny thing is when you actually when I
think about itself is etching every
single thing I find interesting and yet
somehow the movie bores me I don't get
how that happens but every time I think
about like that was interesting that was
yeah that was an interesting idea you
could have done something with that it's
like how does the movie terrible I don't
get what happened
they forgot it yes it forgot to make it
interesting yeah I see cool ideas but we
forgot to put caring we forgot to put
passion we got everyone just says their
lines I think that Oded why the Richard
Burton definitely drags this film done I
think that's part of it too is there is
like a procedure it's almost like a
crime procedural like we're watching CSI
or something against is very CSI has
more passion like a you know this is
very passionate and by the book and by
the numbers and now we have to do this
and we have to do this and when the
player looking like a deer caught in the
headlights like watching happen is with
a hypnotized watch it well I mean that's
her character and even then I just feel
like I get the feeling like she doesn't
know what's going on either like this is
just a confusing set up
she should I get the feeling nobody on
set knew how this was all connecting
yeah um I had never really did so then
they get this third film axises 3 which
I guess it's got a half and a half with
people uh which I totally get I get why
you wouldn't like it I think it's
awesome
yeah I think it's like really fucking
good um but it's one of those movies
where it's like as a sequel to The
Exorcist I can see people being like
this is really kind of far-fetched and
goofy and stuff and doesn't always add
up or make sense honestly I thought it
was more connected to the exit of the
Nexus no that's what I say but but as a
sequel to Exorcist to like fucking
everybody it's like Oh hands down this
is so much better like this is more what
the Exorcist sequel show of Ben um but
it's enjoy because so many people did
not go see it like it as far as I know
it didn't bomb or anything but it was
not like a big hit and a lot of that was
because I'm even um bleep your blade his
name the author Peter bladed gladdie
plays it's not like that yeah like he
didn't want to be called excesses 3 he's
like I want no connection to that last
movie at all
and sure enough a lot of people saw
actually was a loose yeah right no
matter what see this that last one was
so bad that entire you ins I think
because when he it was based on his book
Legion and it's a loose sequel like much
like Exorcist three the movie is it
feels like a loose sequel like it's kind
of a continuation you wouldn't want to
call it like extra exercises to like it
but his point was completely legit which
is listen this is a loose sequel and the
original like screenplay and everything
apparently didn't have the ending that
we got what's a two or three two three
like apparently from what I'm told like
they the studio winner is like you
better put a moment fucking exorcism in
this a burst yeah oh shit and some end
it all Texas is three I didn't want to
call XSS right and put the : X is three
and it makes total sense because this
movie is going at a pretty good clip to
something that is much closer to the
original excesses and really good and
out of nowhere like it's almost a police
procedural like dumb better though than
like Exorcist to us I don't know where
this exorcism gets thrown in at the end
you're like what the fuck and this
priest shows up you're like the fuck is
this fuck did this guy come down I think
he has like one line saying who he is
one scene of him going hmm something's
yes I'm fuckin Caesar dead Bernays like
I'm called and like literate and like
you can to literally telling like you
can almost see like William Peter body
just riding this like and fuck you
studio there's your excesses of like it
is so little effort put in to try to
justify this character's life assistance
I you wanna know what so if I can almost
see him giving like I'm sure he's a good
Catholic writer but you can always seem
just giving this to you the finger dare
you like that like it'll make no sense
no sense but well and the funny thing is
though I actually that bad climaxing it
gets a little goofy and everything but
it's like I still really like that
climax even with the Exorcist it mean
it's idiot little your internals are so
good only works because it's well
directed yeah it makes no sense why
matter when we saw it and he shows up at
the end we're watching with our dad
I saw before I deal it's just like oh so
there's an exorcism it's movie it was
gonna XSS three for a reason and it's
like yeah I guess the author slide I
would I would wanna call it a coup if
you call it Legion and he has the line
about I am Legion fuckin traitor size
what is called school Exorcist 3 Legion
uh but but then they never call it that
in the way they just called exercise
three but yeah that movie is good I mean
it's I mean as far as a the other reason
I don't think he wanted to call it does
a Exorcist to suck Exorcist who was like
what late seventies maybe close to 1980
and this film came out what ninety-one
maybe yeah you're a good one more than a
decade later yeah uh you know I mean it
was like Blues Brothers 2000 bad when it
came to the distance between but it's a
good it's there you know even if you
don't like it which is totally
understandable it is still worth
checking out because there's new demons
dumped on dialog work even they don't
watch the film and at the end of it
you're like this didn't make any sense
it was still quite a ride yeah like it's
a legitimately scary movie the scene
with the giant head chopping clamping
I'll still this day and like the music
they use their that were like it's a god
yeah no it's a what one of the best
buildups and best jump scares you will
see yeah I mean we have to be real
wounded cuz it just so it went sort of
ask re so like holy shit what was that
what was that was I mean it's like it
was the reaction you want from a scary
movie and and I love watching that scene
with on the murders the murders in it
it's a great way to the murders are
always kind of described and the only
see little bits of it like underneath
the blanket or whatever yeah the body
with and what they describe just like
like it's really legitimately creepy
it's like holy fuck it's like drained
his whole blood supply and not a drop
spilled like their the tunneling is a
medical murder it is silly it's silly
but it's done in such a way where it's
like unsurprising it's bhajan it's like
really well done haunted house creepy
well you know how they give you the back
store and you're just thinking really
you a you know like okay well this is
stupid it is this just scary dumb stuff
but you're like okay kind of an effect
on your the great George C Scott's
favorite actor
one of his best performances I think is
in this fucking movie and then
what's-his-face else perform Jamie
Damian of my blankets Jason my something
like that something Miller yes oh yeah
calm Arthur oh man Mac is back as Damian
and of course friend great Errol brand
or at a time of his life as this psycho
he is like I am surprised there was any
set left he chewed so much sighs amazes
oh my god catatonics are so easy to
possess you were asking for an
invitation to the dance on here with us
lieutenant Oh merciful me was i rambling
I mean he is he's chewing it up but it's
it feels worth it feels earned it just
feels like though cuz he he's a fucking
nut and he's insane and he's just
there's all these people are supposed to
be inside the mezcal you know okay I'll
take it
it's fun it's creepy one of the one of
the best Brad Dourif performance like a
child's plays great but I mean this just
blows it out of the water yeah for me no
I mean it's probably like his most fun
performance in a movie I mean it's just
so much fun and - and the funny thing is
it's one of those where I think William
Peter Blatty cuz he wrote and directed
could have restrained himself yeah much
to the film's detriment this is one of
those rare cases words like no you need
to go all-out batshit insane and that's
what made this edge what it's definitely
movies my combined about Hamina so many
times but this time it worked it's
definitely a movie that's directed by an
author because all these are very very
talk heavy a lot of murder are not seen
there talked about and that's something
you know the words are their strength so
they use words to explain stuff but it
is not devoid of some great visuals and
some good scares and good atmosphere I
mean it's all that's got fantastic
visuals and fantastic yeah it just takes
a while to kind of get to it it is a
very talky movie though yeah um and I
don't believe he's funny and I love
these characters we the author is always
right because I know he and freakin had
this huge argument about the first film
yeah and on the ending and the way it
noted on the ending and I
yeah the the new cut they came out with
with the special effects and I had the
original ending that freaking cut that
bladdy like better and I was like no
freaking was right yeah I mean it makes
a ruin anything goes like what's the
point
didn't wreck the movie for me but it
ended it on a note that I'm like that
was like my house that only the weird
thing is the only way it works is as a
set of exercise very um but it does that
to Exorcist threes benefit but to the
Exorcist detriment yeah and in that case
I would say let the first movie be saved
more than the sequel
um but yeah cuz it sets up the what
would be George C Scott's character yeah
and his love of movies and it's also
their movie lovers too which is like the
priest you have a favorite movie the fly
um on that priest yeah what do you know
about exorcism who cares I love it it's
so precess real people dear there is
what I like I like there go easy Angela
C Mon earth are the greatest people on
these were just people they're either
Saints like Hollywood treats priests in
two ways they are either saints or
monsters and I'm like what I love about
the Exorcist excesses theories like
they're normal guys some of them drank
some of them smoke some other kind of
nice some of their kind of jerks some of
them it's like that runs the whole game
ya know anyway there were real
honest-to-god you know our parents um
you know that they played a lot of
churches you know it's at that was got
my dad was a Navy but they also did
stuff at churches my mom could sing and
he orchestrated music and then piano so
what they both orchestrated music and so
we've known a lot of priests and yeah
like The Exorcist
xs/s 1 & 2 or X at 1 2 3 not too uh I
felt like these are real priests iPhones
I feel like I could identify with easier
version of priests more than like you
know other movies I've seen where I'm
just like okay who is that saintly or
always this monster yeah I mean it's
always one of those things so and there
are some monsters out there
oh it's happily ever say tiger seconds
either one or the other always in a
movie and I'm like can you have someone
in like yeah so um yeah there you go
there's our um our totally plenary the
first one to and I'm whispering yeah
scuse good
we sleep through the cycle and we did
yeah y'all some interesting dreams um
see to just if you're super curious yeah
and I can understand if you are but I
mean in some ways it's guilty if it were
shorter it honestly would be a great
guilty pleasure for me but it's too long
yes it's more if it's on TV I will
occasionally like AMC or something so
much it just my mind yeah happened and
if it's on TV I will actually flip back
to it occasion but I won't watch it the
whole way through
yeah I'll try to flip back to catch the
things I like and uh yeah daddy likes
the Suzy's Reagan so yeah there it is uh
more nostalgia we reviews are on the way
we shall see you later yes